[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Give me
one minute, and I'll
show you how local SSD can
add some extra storage space
for your virtual machines.
Local SSD is local
solid state drive
storage for your VM instances.
It provides the lowest latency
and highest performance storage
for temporary use cases.
Local SSDs are physically
attached to the server that
hosts your VM instance, giving
you superior performance, very
high input/output operations per
second, and very low latency,
compared to other
block storage options.
You can customize the VM
shape to your workload,
or attach predefined
shapes designed
for typical use cases, like
data analytics, media rendering,
or gaming.
Your data is secure
because it's encrypted
with an ephemeral encryption
key that's managed and protected
by the SSD.
Local SSDs can be created only
during the instance creation
process.
After creating a local SSD,
format and mount the device.
Local SSDs are designed
for temporary storage use
cases, such as caches or
scratch processing space,
which makes them suitable
for workloads, like media
rendering, data analytics, or
high performance computing.
So next time you're thinking
about adding ephemeral storage
to your VM, take a minute
and look at local SSD.
For more info on
local SSD, check out
cloud.google.com/local-ssd.
[MUSIC PLAYING]